hace unos meses este ex militar taiwanés
disparaba balas reales en el frente
ucraniano
fue el 26 de febrero escuché que
selensky estaba llamando a voluntarios
de todo el mundo y en ese momento me
decidí
al igual que una decena de soldados
taiwaneses
de su casa con esta mochila durante
siete meses estuvo combatiendo en
Ucrania
pondrán pienso que no se puede permitir
que un país autoritario ataque a otro
país más pequeño sentí la obligación de
ir a ayudar a los que estaban siendo
oprimidos de hecho si ayudamos a los
ucranianos ayudamos indirectamente a
Taiwán
Taiwán es un territorio con 24 millones
de habitantes también está bajo amenaza
de Invasión por su poderoso vecino china
en agosto pasado Beijing lanzó por
primera vez misiles sobre el
archipiélago en ese momento
decidió regresar en el caso de que
mueras ponen esta bandera sobre tu ataúd
si no mueres Entonces te la regala
regresó de Ucrania con varios objetos
como la mochila de un soldado ruso que
encontró en el campo de batalla y la
placa de su chaleco antibalas en ella se
lee Taiwán apoya a Ucrania
[Música]
es el mismo nombre de esta asociación
en la Plaza de la Libertad en taipei
conmemoran un año de guerra en Ucrania
entre los representantes electos
invitados está Claire One una diputada
que hace parte de la coalición en el
poder este ucraniano le agradece su
presencia nos hemos sentido muy apoyados
por el gobierno por los políticos ha
hecho una gran diferencia para nosotros
desde el comienzo de la guerra Taiwán se
unió a las sanciones económicas
internacionales y prohibió la
exportación a Rusia de tecnologías de
punta y productos químicos
debemos combatir a Rusia y no hacerle
más fuerte porque no es una democracia
no le importan los Derechos Humanos
este apoyo proviene del Estado taiwanés
pero también representa el apoyo de un
pueblo a otro
son muy comprensivos realmente me
conmueve toda su ayuda desde que comenzó
la guerra a través del envío de
materiales
los apoyamos porque vivimos una
experiencia similar un pasado similar
una historia muy complicada en la que un
país vecino más grande trata de socavar
la soberanía de nuestro país
[Música]
los taiwaneses han donado varios
millones de dólares a esta causa
más de 700 toneladas de material
humanitario han sido enviadas a Ucrania
Ana supo militante prodemocracia las
imágenes de la invasión en Ucrania lo
han conmocionado recolecta y envía los
ucranianos sacos de dormir y ropa
tanto durante el movimiento girasol como
en las manifestaciones de Hong Kong
siempre tuvimos este rol de apoyo
tenemos la capacidad de organizarnos de
movilizarnos Y así fue como pudimos
iniciar esta campaña de donación
hablando con algunos ucranianos nasupó
se enteró que necesitaban drones se puso
entonces en contacto con su primo un
fabricante con sede en taipei el
emprendedor donó Diez de sus aparatos de
reconocimiento
con este drone rápidamente pueden ver lo
que hay a su alrededor tiene un modo
térmico
Esperamos que así en Ucrania los
ciudadanos de a pie puedan proteger
mejor a su comunidad
el costo total para su empresa fue de 50
mil dólares
Espero que los taiwaneses tomen
conciencia de lo importante que es estar
Unidos pero sobre todo Espero mostrarle
al mundo entero nuestra determinación
Ucrania una joven democracia invadida
por su poderoso vecino los taiwaneses
son un tanto más sensible a esta
situación porque La amenaza en su propio
territorio es real consideran que deben
prepararse para una posible invasión
desde que regresó de Ucrania su yuan en
trena los taiwaneses en defensa
territorial civil
todo esto lo aprendí en Ucrania en
Taiwán no se puede aprender
es posible que algunos enemigos logren
desembarcar en Taiwán en esos casos
debemos ser capaces de detenerlos
técnicas de vigilancia y reconocimiento
estos talleres son cada vez más
populares entre los taiwaneses
la Libertad en Taiwán es muy importante
el sistema democrático le da a cada
persona unos derechos cívicos
pero el partido comunista chino no da
esos derechos por eso no quiero que nos
gobierna Incluso si nos promete
beneficios económicos en realidad solo
va a oprimirnos
en enero el gobierno taiwanés triplicó
la duración del servicio militar una
medida aplaudida por estos ciudadanos
temen que la invasión de Ucrania sea un
mal presagio para su propio país